[Música]
[Aplausos]
tengo casi 20 años presentándome como
gabo cruz venezolano
con mucho orgullo lo he dicho en unos
cuantos museos en más de 120
exposiciones donde colaborado de manera
directa en algunas visitas guiadas
charlas seminarios en las universidades
donde estudié también unas cuantas
fiestas parrandas botiquines y hasta en
un té de equis
en 2002 me mudé a parís para estudiar
pero sobre todo para estar con mi abuelo
carlos cruz-diez para usted es un
referente en nuestro país un maestro el
maestro del color para mí además es ese
abuelo que se convirtió en compinche en
mentor y el que me enseñó a ver los
matices de la vida
él fue un artista caraqueño nacido en
1923 un ser maravilloso bondadoso
humilde muy familiar actual él era un
tipo de su época un intelectual un
artista que hizo un aporte fundamental
en la historia del arte desligar el
color de la forma él comprobó que el
color podía ser utilizado como un
elemento autónomo o sea que no
necesitaba la forma ningún tipo de
referencia para existir su propuesta
artística de más de 60 años siempre giró
en torno al color y al espectador
para explicar el origen de su
investigación el abuelo siempre nos daba
el ejemplo del binomio forma color nos
decía que cuando hablamos de una manzana
siempre nos referimos a la manzana roja
a la mesa blanca el color siempre es
utilizado como un elemento descriptivo
de la forma como un complemento
indirecto casi como que si el color
fuera una anécdota de la forma y él
argumentaba que más bien podríamos
hablar solo de rojo o solo de blanco sin
la necesidad de relacionar ese color con
alguna forma
que el color podría ser el sujeto de una
de una investigación artística y en
efecto para él lo fue
en muchas conversaciones que tuve con mi
abuelo él me contaba con mucho orgullo
que su discurso artístico lo estructuró
en venezuela y que luego a mediados de
los 50 tuvo que irse europa a defenderlo
ya debatir sus ideas
en cierta parte se excusaba y me decía
hijito es que en esa época las
coordenadas de la historia no pasaban
por nuestro país tenía que irme nadie
sabía dónde estábamos cómo se iba a
enterar la gente que yo tenía una idea
que yo tenía una nueva propuesta sobre
el color y además en esa época la falta
de comunicación no ayudaba
en esa época también se fueron muchos de
sus profesores y compañeros de la
escuela se fueron a parís porque por ahí
si pasaban las coordenadas de la
historia
y bueno allá en parís pasada sucedió esa
coincidencia histórica que nos
maravillaba nosotros le llamábamos la
universalidad de las ideas
en ese momento parís era el centro del
mundo allá estaban los mejores artistas
y pensadores entonces cuando ellos
llegaron a defender su discurso
artístico se consiguieron con un húngaro
un israelí con brasilero un francés que
tenían preocupaciones similares a las de
ellos
muchas personas pensando en lo mismo
pero a miles de kilómetros de distancia
qué coincidencia
estos artistas consideraban que el arte
debía cambiar que ese arte metafórico
debía cambiar que había que volver a lo
absoluto cambiar el arte trans positivo
y hablar de la realidad misma
ellos contaban que fue ahí en parís
donde se desarrolló todo a ella en parís
se dio la última vanguardia ellos fueron
la última vanguardia a mí personalmente
me pareció que ellos tenían razón en
algo que siempre repetían el arte es
mención
el arte no es arte sanado el arte no es
un homenaje el arte es proponer algo
nuevo es proponer algo de tu época por
ejemplo que más invención que picasso en
su época que pintaba lo que conocía no
lo que veía o que velázquez que hizo las
meninas desde dentro de la obra en una
suerte de autorretrato el pintor de
adentro hacia afuera eso es algo que nos
queda inédito eso no existía en esa
época o precisamente la invención de los
cine ticos que proponían obras
participativas
que generaron una dialéctica con el
espectador
yo no sé si ustedes les pasó igual pero
yo recuerdo que de pequeño nos enseñaron
que un oído del museo se ponía las
manitos atrás ponía cara de que estaba
entendiendo lo todo veías la obra y
luego seguía a la próxima el arte era
contemplativo uno se enfrentaba a la
obra para ver exclusivamente lo que
había propuesto el artista y bueno y si
no entendían lo que pasaba pues te
fregada en cambio esta vanguardia
cinética donde hubo muchos artistas
venezolanos propuso un arte
participativo donde el espectador era
verdaderamente importante uno se
desplazaba frente a la obra y ella se
modificaba en tiempo real
yo pienso que los artistas son de tan
avanzada que el abuelo propuso ser una
obra con campos magnéticos sin
domesticar los campos magnéticos para
demostrar que el color podía vivir sin
soporte así como si fuera una aureola
boreal imagínense poder generar masas de
luz coloreadas aquí en este espacio pero
sin necesidad de ningún soporte o fuente
de luz generar la experiencia del
espacio coloreado del color bruto
y bueno aunque esa obra aún no se ha
podido materializar hicimos una película
que se llama free color muy importante
porque trata de esa obra inconclusa de
habla de ese sueño que tuvo el abuelo y
que la ciencia aún no ha podido realizar
es que imagínense esto un artista
venezolano de más de 90 años propuso
algo que los científicos de la
universidad de caltech allí en
california donde dio clases einstein aún
no han podido resolver es que es que los
artistas de verdad están en otra vida
hay un tema que aprendí con mi abuelo y
me parece relevante sobre todo para las
nuevas generaciones y tiene que ver con
el rol de la familia en el arte
el arte por naturaleza es una aventura
solitaria un artista necesita horas de
concentración reflexión introspección
para desde ahí sacar una conclusión de
su presente y hacer su obra
creo que todos tenemos esas referencias
románticas que muestran al artista medio
loco encerrado en su buhardilla
alcohólico incomprendido y sobre todo
trabajando siempre solo
muchos artistas dentro de su proceso
creativo dejaron a un lado sus afectos a
su familia y entonces por eso resultaba
extraño verlos trabajar con sus esposas
hijos nietos cruz-diez no fue uno de sus
artistas
él entendió que la vida y el arte era lo
mismo
por lo cual el arte de la familia en el
mismo que la casa y el taller era lo
mismo y se dedicó junto a mi abuela a
integrar a toda la familia en esa
aventura él decía que había que vivir en
arte pero esto lo hizo desde la absoluta
libertad él no nos impuso nada no nos
obligó trabajar en esto simplemente nos
propuso el taller como un lugar para
crecer para aprender muchos oficios y
buenos y también para ayudarlo a
desarrollar su propio discurso
cada miembro de mi familia puso su
granito de arena cada generación lo
ayudó a conectarse con su presente y le
brindó ayuda verdaderamente relevante
nosotros lo ayudamos a llevar a sus
talleres a montar las exposiciones a
editar sus libros lo apoyamos con toda
la logística que significa hacer arte
público hace más de 15 años le hicimos
una fundación en eeuu para preservar su
legado inclusive fundamental en panamá
llamado art y cruz para ayudar a otros
artistas a desarrollar su propia obra
nosotros aprendimos un oficio el
artesanal y hoy estamos compartiéndolo
con las nuevas generaciones
yo les puedo decir que incluir a la
familia en el negocio es un acto de
bondad muy grande y me gustaría que lo
recordaran
entonces como les comentaba al principio
de esta charla cuando me fui a vivir a
parís y a trabajar con este gurú del
color comencé a preguntarme qué
significaba hacer de venezuela resulta
que también el colegio me enseñaron que
mi país era especial entre otras cosas
porque tenía riquezas naturales únicas
en el mundo
de pullas en la gran sabana playas
cristalinas en los roques picos nevados
de mérida y los médanos de coro y bueno
la clásica las mujeres más bellas del
planeta y está bien ahí de repente
estamos todos de acuerdo pero como
inmigrante me di cuenta que esos tepuyes
de los que tanto mal van al colegio
resulta que también estaban en brasil y
en colombia y en guyana y en surinam y
en la guyana francesa eso es lo que
forman el macizo guayanés
y también me di cuenta que en francia
por allá abajo en un arca jon cerca de
burdeos hay dunas de arena gigantes qué
bueno que aquí al lado en santa marta en
colombia también tienen picos nevados
es más que las maldivas que es uno de
los países menos poblados de asia tiene
unas playas espectaculares como los
roques entonces en esa crisis de
identidad típica de los inmigrantes me
pregunte que nos hace verdaderamente
diferentes en venezuela mi opinión es
que somos un país de arte
yo cuando me presento digo soy gabo cruz
venezolano de un país de artistas un
país donde hay arte por todos lados
solo caracas mi ciudad natal tiene más
de 400 obras integradas al espacio
urbano de artistas jóvenes y de maestros
super relevantes también que haya en mi
país la gente tomaba tan en serio el
arte que por ejemplo cuando hicieron la
represa de guri en los setentas para dar
la electricidad a venezuela y aparte de
brasil los ingenieros y los arquitectos
llamaron a unos artistas a cruz díez y
alejandro otero
para que esa obra verdaderamente fuese
trascendental
para que dentro de 300 años cuando la
gente visitar ese lugar dijera oye esa
gente si era culta
por ejemplo en la autopista en una
autopista en caracas hay una esfera
gigante de soto que convive con la
belleza de la vela que un caricaturista
como pedro león zapata pudo hacer una
obra de 150 metros de largo en pleno
centro de la ciudad pero saben dónde me
afincó más cuando presento a mi país
como uno de los pocos lugares del mundo
que tiene una iconografía artística como
elemento diferenciador
aquí les cuento otra anécdota cuando
salí a cenar con el abuelo y hablábamos
de lo que pasaba en venezuela siempre
terminamos hablando del famoso piso de
maiquetía
hablábamos de como lo diseñó hace ya
casi 50 años de todas las maquetas que
hizo del material súper resistente que
consiguió en francia para el piso de
como cuando camina sobre el naranja
verde azul y negro aparecía una
infinidad de matices de rosados de
turquesas de amarillo que no estaban en
el soporte de lo que significaba para él
la diáspora también sonreía más porque
sabemos que por ahí volveremos muchos
venezolanos
hablábamos de que él también diseñó la
torre de control del aeropuerto y que
ese proyecto nunca se hizo más y hasta
que le quedaron debiendo unos reales de
ese proyecto
pero lo que más nos asombraba era la
idea del referente estético que
significaba esa obra para el país nos
maravilla vamos pensando que muy pocos
países del mundo tienen dentro de sus
referencias dentro de sus elementos
diferenciadores una obra de arte o un
artista por ejemplo pensábamos
si hoy tú dices torre eiffel en francia
la monalisa aunque da vinci sea italiano
es parís es el louvre de francia ahí
está esa relación obra de arte y país y
eso que francia también tiene vino fue
agrada la sorbona portaviones la ciudad
pero no si nos llamaba la atención que
el arte también fuera parte de esas
referencias seguíamos diciendo el david
de miguel ángel italia
el famoso autorretrato de van gogh es
holanda aunque ese maravilloso país
también tenga molinos y tulipanes luego
dudábamos
el grito de munch buenos y tal vez
noruega pero tal vez para algunos
noruega también son los fiordos y sus
paisajes
decíamos warhol eeuu pero bueno también
puede hacer pollock o coombs o la
coca-cola o la nasa o mickey
es interesante porque buscábamos muchos
ejemplos pero no siempre había consenso
entre un país y una obra de arte o un
artista en fin pasábamos horas hablando
del tema y yo veía como el abuelo se
conmovía diciéndome yo me siento muy
afortunado porque como artista nunca
pensé que la obra de maiquetía sería una
una de las imágenes representativas de
mi país se convirtió en un icono de mi
país qué belleza
y yo les tengo que decir que para mí
personalmente me da mucho orgullo que
hoy en día venezuela sea reconocida por
su inteligencia y por su patrimonio
artístico así que como decía cruz-diez
mi abuelo que viva el arte